I'm Vince Hurnley and I am a Scoutmaster with Troop 73 in Indianapolis, Indiana.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now for you, Scoutmaster,
This is kind of hopeful news
If you're an older person like me, that that you could be on the cutting
edge of culture without even knowing it.
Because if you've ever made soup over a campfire and then gone to taste it
and kind of burned your lips on it, you have made hipster soup.
That's right, Hipster soup, because you ate it before. it was cool.
OK then, Well, they, they, they can all be fantastic.
If you've got a better one, send it in to me.
Hey, this is podcast number two sixty nine.
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green. and hey, we're back after a short hiatus for Memorial Day.
The podcast is well rested and ready to go,
I'm sure you'll be happy to know.
So let's get right into the mailbag.
I heard from John since our last podcast.
He said you'll remember me and my son from a post I helped with last year
because my son is diagnosed with Apzberger's syndrome,
and I shared with you some of the challenges and triumphs we were going
through. I wanted to send you this picture of the both of us looking over
the wall at Fillmont on Mount Baldy.
It was a tremendous experience for us and it was a transformative experience for him.
He's now a life scout and he's thinking about his Eagle project.
Well, John, that is wonderful news and I really appreciate the picture.
John goes on to say: I'm writing now just to let you know that I am beginning
to realize how hard it is to focus on the needs of your scouts
and not let that scouter's ego come into play, but to trust the program.
In three weeks I'm off to summer camp as the adult in charge
And, while others may see special needs scouts as a burden,
I'm looking on it as a huge opportunity for our scouts
to see beyond themselves and support their fellow scouts.
It's an opportunity for our special needs scouts
to have wonderful experiences that will help them in life.
Nobody told me that this one hour a week commitment to scouting
would be one extraordinary quality and personally challenging hour a week.
Well, John, I think that's a pretty good way to put it.
Scouting has tremendous transformative potential for us as adults
and for our scouts as youth.
It's just a wonderful thing
And I really appreciate you getting in touch with me, John
Heard from Josh Kamoli, who's an old, old scouting buddy,
who read our post this past week on the blog.
that is a collection of summer camp resources,
And he says these are awesome.
My oldest is preparing for his first week at camp this summer
And my wife and I are preparing ourselves.
I am going to forward this to her so she can read it to great stuff,
Thank you.
The fact that I knew Josh and worked with him
when he was still a teenager and now his son is old enough
to go to camp for his first year kind of gives me a little bit of pause
to figure out how old I am.
But it's wonderful to hear from you, Josh,
And I do appreciate it
And I'm glad that we can be of some help to you,
And we're going to talk a little bit about this a bit later on in the podcast too.
We had a couple of live chats over the past two weeks
And, in addition to all the wonderful folks who are our frequent
flyers and check in on the live chat, we talked to Mike Franks,
who's a scout master and cub master at Troop and Pack 7082 in Grant, Alabama.
Dave Kish, who is a scout master for Troop 54 in New Jersey, checked in,
as did Michael Durbin, who's the cub master for Pack 205 in Nixon, Missouri.
Dave Peters was on the chat and he is a cub master and assistant scout
master. Rich Kubiak is the scout master of a brand new Boy Scout Troop
in Detroit, Michigan. and Eric Murphy also was on the chat
And he's the scout master of a one year old scout troop, Troop 61 in Erie,
Pennsylvania.
It was great to have everybody on,
And those live chat sessions are announced on the Facebook and Twitter
feeds for scoutmastercgcom,
So keep an eye open for them.
Come on over to scoutmastercgcom and join us.
We have a lot of fun.
And before we go any further, let me take the time to ask a favor,
because I need your help.
I started blogging and podcasting back almost 10 years ago now
And I didn't plan any of this.
I mean, I hear from a lot of folks every week and it's really
heartening to know that I'm able to lend a hand.
What I'm asking in return is that you support the blog and the
podcast by becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer.
Now, to do this, go to scoutmastercgcom, click the support link
at the top of the page and you'll find a number of options.
I'm making a voluntary one time subscription payment to help me
keep things up and running.
I want to take a moment to personally thank Shane Stillwell,
Michael Iovino, Aaron Sloshman, Vince Hurnley, Robert
Kerrigan, David Wilkes, Ron Blaisdell, Suzanne Veliestra
and Matthew Dunham, who've become backers since our last podcast.
Once again go to scoutmastercgcom and become a backer
this week and I'll be sure to thank you during our next podcast.
Well, in this podcast, in scoutmastership in seven minutes
or less, we're going to talk about how parents can prepare
themselves for summer camp and then we've got some email
questions to answer and that will fill up the remainder of the
podcast. So let's get started, shall we?
Scoutmastership in seven minutes or less.
You know I have seen that worried look. so many times
It happens just after parents have brought their scout down to
camp and they have gone in and they see the tent that he's going to be
staying in and they kind of look around a little bit and they look at me
and the other adults are going to be staying there during the week
and they kind of reluctantly start dragging their feet up the trail
and they look a little uncertain that they're ready to do this themselves.
Most of the time the scouts. they're not even thinking right
Because they're at camp, they're happy, they're there with their buddies
and they're looking forward to a great week.
But parents sometimes, hey, this can catch them by surprise
because they concentrate a lot on preparing their scout to go to camp
but they may be unaware of the fact that, hey, this is going to hit them
a little bit. They are leaving their child at a camp in the care of people
who they may know, and really well, and maybe not know really well,
and they may feel a little uncomfortable turning over full time
care of their child to somebody who they have just gotten to know
and they're going to worry about what kind of food the scout will be eating
and who will be looking after daily concerns like clean clothes
and taking showers and making sure they eat and making sure they don't get hurt.
And they kind of wonder if the older scouts are going to be nice
or if they're going to tease them.
And hey, you know, if you've had this experience,
I really don't have to explain it to you.
I mean, what happens if you take your child to camp
and they just don't like camp?
Can they call home or can you check in on them?
Oh, it can be really, really anxious,
And I have seen this anxiety in parents of scouts headed to camp
for the first time for many, many years.
Many of those parents find the experience more difficult
than their children do,
And if they wait for the first contact from camp, the first letter home,
they don't find a whole lot of solace in that either,
because it may sound pretty miserable
even though a scout's having the time of his life.
So the question then becomes: how can we scouts help parents prepare
for how they're going to feel once they've dropped their scouts
off at camp and returned home for a very, very quiet
and sometimes anxious week?
Being separated from your child for this length of time
is a new challenge for every parent, even though many others
have gone through it before and try to be as supportive as possible.
You know it really comes down to the way that you end up feeling
and acknowledging that this causes most parents at least
a little bit of anxiety and distress, that it's a normal part
of your child growing up, that it's temporary
and you're going to feel better about it is going to help.
As somebody who's gone to summer camp for decades,
I understand that most scouts, especially younger ones
will experience some level of homesickness
and they're going to experience some ups and downs
because camp is challenging and it ought to be.
It's a great challenge for them.
But what you need to understand as a parent, is that
his fellow scouts and the scouters that are with him
and the camp staff are all working hard to make this
challenge a positive experience,
And scouts get a lot out of it year after year after year.
While you're concentrating on getting your scout ready
to go to camp, prepare yourself too.
Here's some ways that you can do just that.
The first one sounds pretty easy to understand,
but it bears a little explanation, and that is
first of all, as a parent. think positively.
The overwhelming percentage of scouts have a typically
great time at summer camp.
They absolutely thrive on it and they come home happy.
Your positive attitude about that is important,
because if you're going to be anxious about it
and you're going to worry about it,
you're going to communicate that to them
during the preparations. whether you like it or not,
they're going to kind of get that message.
So, instead of discussing your worries
or how much you're going to miss them
or you don't know how you're going to deal with this week,
talk about the new experiences
that your scout will have at camp
and all the positive potential involved.
Now, anxiety usually comes from something
that we don't know about or understand.
So make sure to ask the scouts who are going to camp
with your scout all the questions you like-
And there are no silly questions,
Really there are none.
If you have a concern or an anxiety or a worry
about exactly what's going to happen at camp,
get one of the scouts who's going and sit down
and ask them all of those questions.
Get them to explain things to you
and it's going to make you feel better.
It's always better to ask than to worry,
And I have talked with a lot of parents
sending their scout down to camp for the first time
who are concerned that I'm going to think they're silly
or they're overreacting
or that they're asking questions
that I haven't heard before.
It goes a long, long way
If you can sit down, be patient with a parent
and do your best to answer all of the questions
that they may have.
Now, as a parent, you need to understand
and respect the way that your scout
will be communicating with you while they're at camp.
Now, in the age of cell phones and things,
you know, it's going to depend a lot upon
the way that the scouts who are taking your scout
to camp are going to work within that technology.
Will they be writing letters home?
Will the letters get home in time?
Will you be able to check in with the camp
or with the scouter?
Look, if you're really anxious about this
and you're anxious about being out of touch
with your scout for a long period of time like this,
talk to the scouter about it
and see what you can do to set up a communication plan
so that you can check in with the scouter or the scout
and realize that that's important both to your state of mind
at home and to your scout's state of mind at camp.
And then, finally, my suggestion to you as a parent:
if you are sending your scout off to camp,
plant something wonderful to do while they're away.
You may have siblings at home that you need to look after.
You have your regular daily routine
that you're going to follow and everything.
Take advantage of the little bit of freedom
that this is going to afford you and make some plans.
It'll be great.
So I understand that. look,
I know when parents are anxious about these types of things
and I don't laugh it off.
I don't think you're being silly,
I don't think you're being childish,
because this is a big challenge, not only for your scout,
but it can be a very big challenge for parents too.
Once again, think positively
And, as you're preparing your scout to go to camp,
talk about all the wonderful things that are going to happen
and the wonderful potential and possibilities of the week at camp.
Try and stay away from telling them how much you're going to miss them
or how worried you're going to be.
Ask the scouts who are going to camp with your scout
all the questions that you like,
because it's always better to know than to worry about something
that you're not quite too sure about.
Understand and plan the way that you're going to be able
to communicate with your scout-
And, once again, that's a great question to ask the folks
who are going to camp with them.
And, finally, take advantage of the fact that you're going to have
a little bit of freedom that week too, and plan something great.
My experience over the past couple of three decades means anything.
What's going to happen is, at the end of that week of scout camp,
your scout's going to come home feeling confident,
having had a great experience and you're going to see that in them
and see the value of this experience both for them and for you as a parent
Boy
scout, Boy
scout.
I need
your
letter, send it by name Email. that is
folks. And here's an
answer to one of your emails. I got this
email
this past week and it begins this way: I believe in the
patrol method, I trust older scouts
and I understand the importance of them having responsibility for younger
scouts, But I'm a bit
shaken by a incident I recently became aware of. A 17 year old
scout was arrested, prosecuted and imprisoned when it was learned
that he had sexually abused two 12 year old
scouts he was tenting with on a camp out. Hearing about this really
brings up a lot of questions in my mind about
safely applying the patrol method in the context of
that kind of risk. Now, I can find
nothing prohibiting a 17 year old from tenting with two
12 year old scouts in the guide to
safe scouting. I am reconsidering, though,
what you've often said about patrols camping some
distance from adults and the kind of
limited supervision you seem to advocate. Well, learning about an
incident like you describe is certainly, certainly upsetting,
and you're asking very
good questions, And I think these
are good questions for any scouter to have in the
front of their mind at all times. Are we safely applying
the patrol method? Are we cognizant of
possible risks involved when we entrust older
scouts with the care of younger scouts? Now, without looking at
any actual statistics, my guess is that
the statistical risk of sexual abuse from
an older scout would be about equal
to the risk of being hit by
a falling tree while we're out camping. Every once in a
while you hear about some tragedy where a dead tree
falls on a tent or there's some kind
of accident like that, but it's pretty rare.
Now, if we know
that a risk is present, the first question we
need to ask is how we manage
that risk prudently Because, let's face it,
we are never going
to create a situation that is totally 100%
risk free. But looking at the
specifics of the incident that
you related, I think that the
age disparity between the scouts who
were sharing a tent is one place where
the risk could certainly be mitigated. It's prudent to watch
for those age disparities and make sure they're
corrected. We need to be
aware of who's sharing a tent with who, what the arrangements are,
the ages, and we need to
watch out for big age disparities, because that presents some
percentage of risk that we can easily
manage. And the other thing
to think about too is just the fact
that three scouts were sharing a tent. I wouldn't say that
three scouts sharing a tent is absolutely wrong in
every single circumstance, but I think we
should be aware of something: Scouts in a situation
like this usually are going to
do better in even numbers, And that's one of
the reasons why we put a third
in there, And that's not all
that uncommon sometimes. but a third in
there means that you've got a better
chance of somebody not really being part
of the group. So think even numbers
this way. That can also mitigate
the risk in this particular instance
and it can just
make the group dynamic a better one for
scouts. Now, the distance of
the scouts in that tent from the nearest adult
may or may not
have had a part in the incident you
describe. So how do we
assure ourselves that if scouts are
camping some distance away from
us, where we might not
hear or be able to
directly supervise every single thing that
goes on, how can that be
prudent? Well, the distance question.
and what I recommend: letting patrols set up
their own campsite at some distance from
where the adults are. are not going to
tell you specifically what that distance is,
because it wouldn't fit every
single situation, But you know enough
of a distance for them to feel
that they're operating autonomously and they have
actual, real responsibility. The fact
that they're
at that distance doesn't mean out of
sight, out of mind, we're not watching or
supervising or modernizing what happens.
that would be completely
irresponsible. We should be walking
around a little bit and looking at the
sites and looking at how
things are going, as should our older
scouts- a senior patrol leader
or somebody like that- and the scouts should
be aware that we are cognizant
of their activities, that we know what's
going on, and it's always been
my habit to walk through everybody's
campsite after lights out to
make sure that the lights are
actually out and just to kind
of monitor things and let the scouts
know that we're out there and
we're keeping an eye on things. When we hear about
things like this, it's absolutely horrifying and
it always makes
us think about what we can do
to prevent things like
this from happening. If you ask yourself
that question and you give it
a little bit of thought, the actions that would
be required to absolutely have zero
risk and absolutely
prevent something
like this from ever
happening are theoretically possible, but
they could change
things out of proportion to
the actual risk. I began this answer
by talking about the statistical possibility of
an incident like
you described happening in a dead
tree falling on a tent
and harming a scout, because there is an
actual risk that a tree could
fall over on a sleeping scout.
one reaction to mitigate
that risk could possibly be that
we never camp around trees or
we remove all
the trees from our campsites, and certainly taking either
of those actions would 100% guarantee that
we would have
absolutely no risk of a tree falling
and hitting a scout. imagine how trying to
mitigate the
risk absolutely would change everything
that we do. a more prudent approach
would, of course, be
making sure that
we're rare. hey, every once in
a while you hear about this-
a tree falls down and hits a scout
and harms them. so we look around
and we don't pitch
our tents around dead trees from
our campsites. that
would be a
much more prudent way to handle the risk. but I certainly understand
how upsetting hearing about an incident
like this is and feeling that
we
should take every single possible measure
to absolutely guarantee that
this would never, ever happen, and
I agree to
some extent. but once again I'm
trying through this tree illustration to say: look, this
is always going
to be a risk. you have to understand
both the level of the risk and the prudent actions
to take to prevent it from
happening. and once again, I
think the age disparity question and the number of
scouts sharing a tent probably would have handled
that anyway. but the truth is
is that all of
these measures could have been in place and there still could
have been an incident. now I think societally
we've developed a propensity
to overstate and sensationalize
what are very statistically
small risks
to our children and
we get terrified, and rightfully so, and
we react over
easily, and rightfully so. but
if we study
the risk logically and we learn what
is an actual and a perceived danger,
we get a better
idea of the actual risk involved and how to
mitigate
it prudently. here's another email that
came in over the past couple
weeks. I'm a merit badge
counselor participating in summer camp and I will be
counseling. the game design merit badge, of
course- is to
get the merit badge completed while the scouts are
there and for the most
part I'll find it very easy to accomplish this goal.
but I have one
dilemma. one requirement is designing
and prototyping a game. the requirements
pretty clear
that this is an individual thing, that each scout is
supposed to make their own prototype, but I'm wondering
if it might be
okay to have them do this in a group. my concern is is
if scouts do
this individually, that most are not
going to be able to finish the badge and that they're there
at camp and that seems to
be a very important goal. I know that there
are a lot of merit badge counselors who do not stick
to the exact requirements of the badge and, after all, the
badge that I'm
going to be counseling is not an EU-required
badge with important skills like life
saving or
first aid. now, I thought about
having the scouts do their prototype game before coming to
camp, but as a counselor,
I'm supposed to approve the concept first
the other counselor. I'm
going to be working with the group work idea,
but I'm on the
fence with this. I see a lot of pros and cons on both sides. which
do you think
is the better route? well, I think you
probably answered your own question. if the requirement is
clear about this being individual
rather than group work,
then you've really answered
your own question, haven't you? I
would rather not
give you too much opinion here, because you've told me
that the requirement is
clear about this being individual
work, and that is what
I'm going to propose to group work. if group work was
an option, it would be right
there in the requirement. so my opinion or
your opinion or anybody else's opinion
isn't what's important here. it's really just very
clearly stated policies
that you yourself understand
and have agreed to
adhere by as a merit badge
counselor. now, I understand your
desire to stay within the spirit of
the activity and to make it
possible for the scouts to finish the badge while
they're at camp. but you're kind of
painted into a corner here, because you're talking about
a
general policy that states unequivocally that
counselors cannot alter requirements by
adding to them
or taking away from them. now we could argue
the merits of that policy and we could
argue
the merits of the way that the requirement is
written. but it's pretty plain
that we're obligated as counselors and as
scouts to
follow the rules. and while we're on
the subject, I'll simply add that
this little conundrum that
you brought up is repeated time and
time and time again because
we've developed this
type of approach where we
are doing merit badges with
large groups of scouts when they're
really intended to be done individually with the counselor,
because
that's a very important part of the program.
we have to some
extent commodified summer camp experience by
the number of merit
badges that scouts complete summer camp and by
the fact that he brings home no partial completions.
I think that those
things kind of miss the
point and they turn our
summer camp experiences and the merit
badge program into something that it
really shouldn't be. but you know, that's
kind of a story for another time. I
think as a
counselor you've answered your own
question. things are written pretty
clearly. you've made a commitment
to follow them as they're written and that's the best
advice that I have for you. I heard from Andrew
Kembor who is with True56
in Lawrenceville, Georgia. he said I am
new to
Boy Scouts and I'm trying to figure out exactly what a patrol
can and can't do and
what kind of adult supervision is required. if
a patrol plans
a meeting at our house, for example, do I
need to have too deep leadership present?
what about if that
patrol wants to do an activity
together, like go on a hike or a patrol camp
out? exactly what kind of
adult supervision does that
sort of thing require. it's been difficult
to find any definitive
rules about this. while I
understand the
emphasis and the support for the patrol system,
it's been kind of
difficult to find rules about how much supervision
a patrol needs in
a given situation. well, Andrew, it's actually
there and
it's all pretty
easy to understand if you look in
the Guide to Safe Scouting, because on page 8
the Guide to Safe
Scouting says this, and I quote too:
deep leadership on
all outings is required to
registered adult leaders,
or one registered leader
and a parent of
a participating scout or other adult,
one
of whom must
be 21 years of age or older, are required
for all trips and
outings. there are a few
instances, such as patrol activities,
of adult leaders is
not required and adult leadership
may
be limited to training and guidance
of the patrol leadership.
with the proper training,
guidance and approval by the
troop leaders, the patrol can conduct
day hikes and service projects. appropriate
adult leadership must
be present for all overnight
scouting activities. further
from the Guide
to Safe Scouting, quote: one on one
contact
between adults and scouts is prohibited.
one on one contact
between adults and youth members
is not permitted. in situations that require
personal conferences, such as
scout master conferences, the meeting is
to be conducted within the view
of other adults and youth.
so, Andrew, let's look
at your specific questions in the light of
what I just read. if the patrol plans
a meeting at your house, do you need to
have too deep leadership? well, no, you do
not need to have two adults
present, but you would avoid
one on one contact
between adults and scouts. what about
if the patrol wants to
do an activity together, like go on a
hike or something like that? once again, the guide
to safe scouting says there
are a few instances, such as those
types of activities, where the presence of
adult leaders is not required, and
that your role as an
adult is to make sure that the
patrol leadership understands what their responsibilities
situation is. Andrew also
asked: what about a
patrol camp out? well, that
changes things, because an appropriate
adult leadership has to
be present for all overnight scouting
activities, and appropriate adult
leadership is described
as two registered adult
leaders, or one registered leader
and the parent of a participating scout
or other adult, one
of whom- either that adult
leader or the parent or
the other adult- needs to be at least 21 years
of age or older. When we're
talking about patrols and patrol activities,
patrol meetings and patrol camp outs.
we know that activities
that don't involve an overnight camp out,
they don't need to have adults right
there present, so long as the
scouts involved have assured themselves that
patrol leadership is trained and capable
of undertaking that kind
of thing responsibly, that too
deep leadership is required
on overnight camp outs
and that in no
wise, at no time, do
we have one on one
contact with a scout that
is not able to be
monitored or seen by
other adults or
scouts. and finally, I'll just
add, Andrew, the age of
the guys in the patrol is going to affect
your comfort level as
a scouter with exactly what they're
trusted to do. their age, experience and
maturity is a factor in
making a decision about this. if you are confident
that you've spoken with
the patrol leadership and that they are
cognizant of their
responsibilities and they can conduct
an activity safely without your direct
supervision,
I think that's fine
and the guide to safe scouting says that
it's fine. but if you have
a younger patrol and you're not exactly confident in
that happening and you think they
need more direct supervision, that's fine too. And
I'll tell you, some patrols of 15
year olds that I've
had require more supervision than some
patrols of 12 year olds. it all
depends on the scouts. there are some hard
and fast policies there, there are some
rules of thumb and there are just
some common sense things
that all have to factor into
keeping scouts safe in those situations
where they're doing an
activity or having a meeting or doing
a camp out with their patrol. Hey, if you
have a question for me, you can
get in touch and you're going to find out
how to do that in just a moment.